S
ACRO OUR BORDER.
JASO JOINING US NOW FMER
ACTING DEPARTMENT OF HOMEND
SECURITY SRETARY DURING THE
TRUMP ADNISTRATION CHAD WOL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINI
.
U WATCHED THEITTLE GIR TO
HEAR SHE A HER MOTR BOTH
PERIED THERE IN T ARIZONA
DESERT, I MEAN,  IS HUM
TRFICKING, IT I REAL.
IT'S N JUS NBERS OFEOPLE
COMING ACROSS, REAL HUMAN BEINGS
THATRE LOSING THEIR LIVBECAUSE E
UNITED STATES.>> WELL, IS ABSOLT
AND THAS A HEARTEAKING STORY
BUT WE SEE LOT OF THO
THUGHOUT THE COURSE O THE
YEAR THROUGHOUT IS CRISIS.
BUT WEAVE TO REMEMBER THA THE
BIN ADMINISTRATION I
ENCOURING INDIVIDUALS, WERE
SEEING HISRIC NUMBERS, MONTHAFTS
DEATHSND BORDERATROL ARE
EING EVERY DAY AND W ARE
SEEING MORE IN CUSTODY DEATHSBEF
PEOPLE CROSSING T BORDER EVERY
MONTH.BORDER POLICY THA THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS PARTAKE
LA SEVERAL MONTH IS AERYINHUMANG
SOME DEVASTANG CONQUENCES.
JAN: THERE WERE SOME 65,0
PEOPLE THACAME ACRS AS
UNACCOMPANIEMINORS.
DERSTANDING THAT RGHLY A
THIR OF THOSE ARE UCCOUNTED
FOR.
THE BIDENDMINISTRATION HAS
TOTALLY LT TRACK WITH THEM.
THEY THOUG THEY COULD GET A
TELEPHONE NUER AND CALL A
ECK ON THEM B TY CAN'T
FIND THEM NOW.
HOW IS THAT NOT HUMAN
AFFICKING AND WE AOW SO MAN
UNACMPANIED MORS JUST LOOSE
WITHIN THENITED STATES OF
AMERIC
>> WELL, WE NEE TO KEEP ININD
THAT THIS IS THE SAME
ADMINISTRATIONHAT ROLLED BACK
TRUMP-A VETTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THOSE SAM SPONSORS.
WE HAD PUT IN PLACE A VERY
ROBUST SPONSORING PCEDURES TO
MAKE SUR THAT WENEW WHO TSE
INDIDUALS WERE AND THATE
WERE PLACING THESE MINORSITH.
IS ADMINISTRATN ROLLED BACKTHOSG
THEM, THEY DON'TNOW WHERE THE
ARE  WHICH MAKES IT EVEN MOR
DIFFICT FOR THESE MINS TO
SH UP TO THE IMMIGRATION
PREEDINGS WHICH ARE RUIRED
TO DO BY L BUT IF YOU CAN'T
EVENOCATE THEM, YOU CAN'T
CATE THEM OR THEIRPONSOR,
THEN YOU NEGLECT THERE NOT
SHOWINUP FOR COURT AND SO IT'
EXACTLYIGHT, JASON.
IT'S HUMAN TFFICKING REALLY A
ITS WORSE.
JASON: WELL,HE OTHER THING
AT'S BEING TRAFFICKED ARE
LOT OF DRUGS.I MEAN, FENNYL IS Y
RE DANGEROUS, MORE DEAY THAN
HEROIN ANDET THE BEN
MINISTRATION IACTUALLY
LOING TO FOLLOWING THROUGH ON
THISDEA THAT THEY -- THESECRIMET
NALTIES FORHEM, HOW IS THISGOINE
FE AND SECURE?
>> WELL, IT' N.
AT THE END OFHEAY, I THINK
FOLKNEED TO KEEP IN MI THAT
THE HISTORI NUMBER OF FOLKS
THAT WE E SEEING CSS THE
RDER ENRIC THE CARTELS EVERY
DAY FORVERY INDIVIDUA
CROSSI THE BORDE IT'S 5 T
$10,0 THAT THEY PAY CARTEL
MBERS.
THE CARTELS ARE PTING THA
NEY BACK INTO ELICIT BUSINESS
AND THEY CTINUE TO TRAFFIC
ILLEGAL NARCOTI AND THE 200%
THE SEGMENT, IS ONL THE AMOUNTTS
GETTING THROUGH A WHY DO WE
KN THAT BECAUSEORDER PATROL
AGEN ARE NO LONGE ON THE LINE
DOG THEIR NATIONAL SURITY
SSION, THEY A BACK IN
FACILITIES TRYING  CARE FOR
ALL OFHE MIGRANTS TT ARECOMINGCT
T ONLY A SMALLERCENTAGE OF
WHAT'S COMIN INTO THE BORDER
FUEL BY THE CARTELSND FUELED
THE BIDEN ADMINTRATION'S
POLICIES.
JASON: YEAH, DRUG CARLS KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOINGNFORTUNATELY
BUT THIS ADMINISTRATIO DOESN'T
BUT HE KAMAL HARRIS, SHE'S ON
TOP OF I THERE SHOULD BE
THING TO WORR ABOUT I
FORM ACTIN